madame monsieur bonsoir après 46 heures
de cauchemar à l'école maternelle de
neuilly des policiers du raid ont libéré
ce matin les six filles est encore
retenu en otage ainsi que la jeune femme
médecin du corps des sapeurs pompiers de
paris qui avait passé la nuit avec elle
est donc loin entendront le témoignage
tout à fait capital
le preneur d'otages a été abattu de
trois balles dans la tête précis du
dénouement avec valeria g4 petite fille
effrayée accroché au cou des policiers
du raid
il est 7 heures 25 nous assistons sans
encore le savoir al épilogue de la prise
d'otages ces enfants viennent juste
d'être emportée de la salle de
maternelle où il était détenu
apprenant que le ravisseur a été tué le
petit groupe regagne ensuite calmement
le parc de l'école à peine 30 minutes
plus tard edouard balladur le premier
ministre se présente à l'entrée
principale une courte visite suivie de
celle de son ministre de l'intérieur
pressé par les journalistes charles
pasqua est laconique mais heureux et là
forcément les familles des petits otage
sorte ensuite une à une leurs n'est pas
aux grandes déclarations mais à
l'émotion il est épais très content très
content
à 8 heures on ignore encore les
conditions réelles du dénouement
nicolas sarkozy le maire de neuilly qui
a participé aux négociations apportera
un premier témoignage sur le rallye
soeur vit c'est beaucoup tendues et là
ça fait maintenant près de 18 heures
qu'on n'arrivait plus à sortir un enfant
et c'était plus facile au départ parce
que comme toutes les deux heures en
arriver à en sortir
et puis tout d'un coup c'est bloqué il
s'est dit ses enfants c'était sa
protection voulait pu en sortir il y
avait plus rien à faire ça il voulait
plus rien entendre on a tout essayé j'ai
été chercher l'argent il était très
méfiant il est toujours content et il a
voulu absolument je lui donne les le
montant des devises en deutschemark et
en dollars- enfin bref il ya des
discussions qui étaient irréels
puis on aperçut enfin ces deux femmes
d'exemplaires et jean lambert médecin
capitaine des pompiers de paris et
laurence dreyfuss la jeune institutrice
côte à côte comme sur cette image
pendant 47 eur elles ont protégé les
enfants en fin de matinée l'école avait
presque retrouvé une allure normale
la rentrée des classes et pour mardi une
rentrée sourire aux lèvres m